Salut, c’est Jhon Rachid.
Aujourd’hui, si on part
aux États-Unis avec Brut,
c’est à cause de cette photo.
Un homme et sa fille
sont morts juste là.
On les a retrouvés
le visage dans l’eau,
un homme et son enfant,
dans cette rivière.
Le père s’appelait Oscar,
il avait 25 ans.
Sa fille, Valéria,
avait 2 ans.
Deux migrants
qui venaient du Salvador,
noyés dans le Rio Grande.
Cette photo,
elle a fait le tour du monde
et comme beaucoup de gens,
c'est normal,
elle m’a choqué.
Ils étaient fatigués d'attendre,
ils ont attendu trop longtemps ici
et ils voulaient passer de l’autre côté.
Ça a l’air très proche
mais c’est très dangereux,
extrêmement dangereux.
Avec Brut, on a voulu
comprendre la réalité
derrière cette photo.
Alors on est partis à la frontière
des États-Unis et du Mexique.
Là où Oscar et Valéria
ont vécu leurs derniers jours :
dans le camp de migrants
de Matamoros,
à seulement 500 mètres
de la frontière américaine.
On n'est pas bien ici,
parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d’insécurité ici.
C’est un enfer.
Des migrants
d'Amérique centrale désespérés
et parmi eux, des dizaines
de milliers d’enfants :
les premières victimes
d’un Trump
qui rêve de fermer
les frontières.
Le mois dernier,
20 000 enfants migrants
sont entrés illégalement
aux États-Unis.
C'est une augmentation
catastrophique.
Ces enfants sont exploités
par des coyotes vicieux
et des gangs impitoyables.
Comme d'habitude,
toujours aussi trash.
Dans le camp de Matamoros
au Mexique,
il n’y a pas d’ONG.
Plus de 1000 réfugiés
dont 300 enfants
vivent sans l’eau potable
et dorment dans des tentes.
Bonjour mon petit,
comment ça va ?
Salut !
Quand ils arrivent,
on leur donne un burrito,
un granola et un cookie.
Si ces familles
tiennent le coup,
c’est grâce à l’aide
de bénévoles américains
qui, chaque jour, passent
la frontière
pour leur apporter
à manger et à boire.
C’est vraiment
une situation très triste
et voir la souffrance
de ces enfants,
les voir manger à même le sol,
ça me brise le cœur.
J’ai fait la guerre,
j’étais prêt à donner ma vie
pour les États-Unis
et quand je vois
ce qu'ils font maintenant,
je me sens meurtri
dans mon corps et mon âme.
Ce n’est pas le pays
pour lequel je me suis battu.
- Vous êtes combien à dormir ici ?
Où dormez-vous ?
- Dans ma famille, on est 5.
3 filles, un petit garçon et moi.
Je mets ma petite famille
à l’intérieur de la tente
et moi, je dors ici sur le sol.
Pourquoi devons-nous rester ici ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on a fait
pour mériter ça ?
Est-ce qu’on a fait
quelque chose de mal ?
Ce n’est pas juste et
c’est injuste avant tout
pour mes enfants
et pour les enfants
de toutes les autres femmes
qui sont ici.
Je prie Dieu
et ce que je demande,
c'est qu’il nous donne de la force,
nous, tout ce qu’on demande,
c’est une autre vie pour nos enfants.
Qu'est-ce que j'en sais ?
Que vont-ils faire de nous ?
Elle, c'est Ximena Lucia.
Elle a 4 mois.
- Et elle ?
- Elle s’appelle Valeria Cristel
et elle a 9 mois.
- 9 ans !
- Oui, 9 ans.
On est venus en Amérique du Nord
pour réaliser notre rêve.
Le rêve de ma fille,
c’est de devenir vétérinaire.
On ne peut plus
rentrer au Honduras,
c’est trop dangereux là-bas.
C’est pourquoi on demande
la protection des États-Unis.
Salut les enfants !
Vous avez tous des vêtements ?
Il y a une famille en bas
qui utilise l’eau de la rivière
pour laver leurs vêtements.
- Tu viens d'où ?
- Du Salvador.
- Tu connais la date
de ton audition ?
- Oui.
- Quel jour ?
- Le 23 octobre.
C'est pour ça qu'on attend.
- Dans 6 semaines.
Une chose qu’il faut comprendre,
c'est qu'à partir du moment
où ils sont de l’autre côté,
ils ont le droit de faire
une demande d’asile.
C’est le sol américain.
Donc vous pouvez voir la tentation.
Je suis un très bon nageur,
je ne tenterais pas
la traversée.
Il y a deux semaines,
un homme se lavait
en bas de la rivière
et il s’est noyé.
Le courant est vraiment
très dangereux.
Ce camp de réfugiés
est un parfait résumé
de la politique migratoire
de Donald Trump :
tous les moyens sont bons
pour décourager ceux
qui veulent rentrer
aux États-Unis,
y compris emprisonner
des enfants de migrants.
L’an dernier,
plus de 2300 enfants
ont été séparés de leur famille
et placés dans des centres
de détention aux US.
Des centres de détention
qui sont forcément
interdits aux journalistes,
alors pour en parler,
nous avons rencontré
une avocate en colère
qui, elle, a pu y rentrer.
Je m'appelle Karla Vargas,
je suis avocate
pour l'association
"Texas Civil Rights Project"
ici à Alamo, au Texas.
Les migrants appellent
ce centre de détention
la “perrera“
ou la cage pour chiens.
Le gouvernement ne fait
aucune différence
entre l'hébergement
d'un adulte
et ses conditions de détention
et celles d’un enfant.
Un enfant de 16 ans est mort
dans le centre de détention
de Weslaco
après être tombé malade.
Il s’appelait Carlos Gregorio
Hernández Vásquez,
il avait 16 ans.
Ils les gardent dans
un bâtiment comme celui-ci :
au secret.
Ils n’ont aucun accès
à un avocat,
à leur famille,
à qui que ce soit si ce n’est
peut-être leur consulat.
J’ai vu des enfants, des bébés
retenus dans ce centre
de détention.
Les lumières
sont toujours allumées,
les migrants appellent aussi
cet endroit “Hieleras”
ou la glacière.
Et c’est parce qu’on les garde
à des températures
qui sont frigorifiques,
surtout pour des enfants.
Quelle que soit la crise
qui se passe ici, à la frontière,
je veux être très claire,
c’est une crise mise en place
et entretenue par notre gouvernement.
Mais à Brownsville,
il n’y a pas que des anti-Trump.
Dans cette ville américaine,
à seulement 5 minutes
de la frontière mexicaine,
le président a ses fans.
Et devinez quoi ?
Ils nous ont donné
rendez-vous
au stand de tir de la ville.
Je pense que Trump
fait du bon boulot
en essayant de réguler
le flux des clandestins.
Des parents
arrivent aux États-Unis
avec leurs enfants dans les bras
et c’est plus facile pour eux
d’obtenir des papiers
avec un enfant.
C'est bien plus facile.
Je trouve ça grave.
Et maintenant,
ils font des tests ADN
sur les enfants
et leurs supposés parents.
On se rend compte
qu'ils n’ont pas de lien de parenté,
alors ils sont déportés.
Maintenant que
les enfants sont ici,
on en fait quoi ?
Les enfants sont dans une position
bien pire que les adultes.
Pourtant, ils les font traverser
comme si c’étaient des objets.
Il y a des enfants de 3 ans,
de 2 ans, même des bébés
qui franchissent la frontière
et après, on les retrouve
en train de flotter dans la rivière
tout ça parce que
des parents ont payé des passeurs.
Venez ici légalement,
signez les papiers,
faites les démarches,
payez les frais, tout ça.
En venant légalement,
ça me va.
Mais si vous venez en attendant
une main tendue
et que vous vous attendez à
tout avoir gratuitement… sûrement pas.
Dans 1 an, Trump
joue sa réélection
et il est déjà en campagne.
Son discours, forcément,
n'a absolument pas changé.
Comme il y a 4 ans,
il tape sur les migrants,
les parents
et les enfants.
Il serait bête d'arrêter,
ça lui a déjà bien réussi.
Tous les candidats démocrates
à l’élection présidentielle
sont en faveur
d’une assurance maladie gratuite
pour tous ces clandestins
étrangers.
Ils veulent donner plus aux clandestins
qu’aux citoyens américains,
vous le voyez bien.
En tant que président,
je ne laisserai jamais les démocrates
prendre l’argent
de votre assurance maladie
pour le donner à des personnes
qui sont illégalement dans notre pays.
Merci.
Vous avez compris
maintenant,
Trump a une seule
obsession : l’immigration.
Et son rêve tient toujours,
c’est de construire
un mur de 3000 km
qui séparerait
les États-Unis du Mexique.
Mais avec Brut,
on a voulu finir ce reportage
avec des citoyens américains
qui rêvent d’autre chose,
des citoyens
qui n’oublient pas
qu'eux aussi, leurs ancêtres
viennent d’ailleurs,
un peu comme chez nous
et je suis le premier concerné.
On ne peut pas
changer le président,
on peut juste tenter de réparer
les dommages qu’il a commis
jusqu’à ce qu’il s’en aille,
qu'il ne soit plus qu'un horrible chapitre
de l’histoire des États-Unis.
Ça m'a mis très en colère,
ça m'a donné envie d’agir,
de prendre la parole.
J’avais besoin de me rappeler
la cause en laquelle je crois.
J’ai donc créé avec un artiste
ces tatouages.
L’un est pour Alonso,
l’autre pour Jessica.
Jessica est morte,
elle était malade,
ses parents étaient dans
un autre centre de détention.
Elle était anéantie
et refusait de manger
et elle en est morte.
Felipe, lui, était déshydraté,
il était très malade,
séparé de ses parents.
Il n’a pas reçu les soins
dont il avait besoin et il est mort.
Voilà les victimes
d’un échec politique,
séparer des enfants de leur famille,
c’est la chose la plus horrible
que j’ai connue dans ma vie.
Jamais je n’aurais cru que
les États-Unis en arriveraient là.
Mais on le vit,
on le voit bien,
tous les jours
quand je franchis la frontière,
je vois les victimes
d’une politique raciste,
je vois des enfants malades
et qui ont besoin d’aide.